Tyler Perry paid the bill for thousands  of folks buying groceries he paid for  all the senior citizens and high-risk  shoppers and dozens at dozens rather of  Kroger's and winn-dixie stores in  Atlanta and New Orleans the customer's  reactions were priceless when they found  out the news at the cash register watch  this Tyler Perry paid for your grocery  bill today I'm not kidding so we just  want to thank you for shopping at  winn-dixie and how it reminds you to  just stay safe not kidding over the  weekend Perry also helped servers who  were out of jobs he gave 42 employees at  his favorite lana restaurant 21 thousand  dollars to share gail glad we are not  surprised at christmas he can you play  Santa whenever there's a crisis you can  expect Tyler to step in he's touched by  it so he does something about it